cuando estallaron los enfrentamientos en
jerusalén cuando los disturbios se
extendieron a la franja de gaza y luego
se extendieron las ciudades de todo
israel cisjordania mantuvo la calma pero
ahora se ha creado un tercer frente en
hebrón en ramala y nablús a cientos de
palestinos se enfrentaron con el
ejército israelí para los manifestantes
todos los campos de lucha están
conectados
vamos a llamar a la ciudad de naplusa
sus aldeas y campamentos respondieron al
llamado el llamado de jerusalén y el
llamado de gas a la plus a sus aldeas y
campamentos se levantaron por los
mártires de jerusalén y los de gas
los palestinos tienen sus razones en
esta lucha la amenaza de que varias
familias palestinas sean desalojadas de
sus hogares en jerusalén-este en una
batalla judicial por la propiedad de la
tierra en la que están construidos sus
casas los enfrentamientos en la mezquita
de al-aqsa también conocida como el
monte del templo este 15 de mayo es una
fecha muy sensible se conmemora el
aniversario de la nakba o la catástrofe
en árabe y que hace referencia a la
creación del estado de israel en 1948
seguida de la primera guerra
árabe-israelí y la expulsión de miles de
palestinos de sus tierras los disturbios
actuales pueden dar lugar a más
enfrentamientos la lucha es la más
violenta que se ha registrado en los
últimos siete años el bombardeo israelí
a objetivos de hamas en la franja de
gaza ha causado decenas de muertes de
civiles y una destrucción generalizada
mientras tanto cerca de dos mil misiles
han sido disparados por hamas contra
israel matando también a varios civiles
en una escalada de la que no hay
indicios de su cese